Шановні колеги з Марією Іонова і ми
тільки вийшли з військового госпіталя де
спілкувалися з пораненими військовими
так ось після важкого поранення після
демобілізації вони всі будуть
декларуватися будуть декларуватися
депутати сільради які сьогодні нічого не
вирішують і не отримують жодної копійки
від держави а хто не буде декларуватися
після вашого закону після вашого закону
не будуть декларувати ці люди хто живе
на невідомі кошти і виконує функції
держави хто сьогодні з собою підмінили
уряд парламент і зокрема владу сьогодні
військові щодня пишуть нам вони очікують
це голосування подекларуванню і вони
вважають що всі ми маємо повернутися до
закону прийнято нашою командою про
публічне прозоре декларування чиновників
і так і буде я переконна голоси ми на це
знайдемо але вам не соромно буде
натискати кнопку за те що військові
поранені з ампутація будуть
декларуватися А оці жирні морди які
крадуть живуть на корупційні конверти
присутні на всіх нарадах не маючи
допуску не маючи допуску до держтаємниці
управляючи вами вказуючи вами Як вам
голосувати підміняючи собою уряд даючи
вказівки кожному з вас вони
декларуватись не будуть вам не соромно
що пан Арестович який сьогодні плює в
очі нашим військовим і говорить я буду
жерти амари і їздити на лексусі А ви
воюєте він не буде декларуватися тому що
радіна і її комітет провалили поправку
подекларуванню позаштатних радників
офісу президента
подекларуванню наглядових рад
подекларуванню тих хто живе за бюджетні
кошти а це держпідприємства друзі
Давайте ми це виправимо я пам'ятаю Настю
радіну Прекрасну антикорупціонерку Яка
правильно виступала що всі хто має хоч
якесь відношення до державної копійки
має декларуватися що всі хто може
впливати на державні рішення має
показати за що за Які кошти він живе
Сьогодні я не знаю хто її тримає за руки
може це офіс президента але давайте ми
покажемо що ми можемо за це
проголосувати що ми готові йти до
Європейського Союзу щоб ми готові
показувати хто как же як живе що ми
знаємо що ті хто краде на будівництві
будуть відповідати ті хто крадуть на
тендерах ідуть вказівки міністерствам
будуть відповідати вони покажуть свої
статки друзі Ви всі будете декларуватися
А ті хто дає вам вказівки декларуватись
не будуть тому я дуже прошу щоб ми з
вами разом зараз виправили цю помилку
яка трапилася вчора на комітеті коли
пані радіна і п'ять сміливих членів
комітету антикорупційної політики
проголосували задекларування позаштатних
радників офісу президента які не
вилазять з марафону які розповідають що
робити парламенту що робити уряду коли
вони каву будуть прийти в Криму коли
вони переможуть як має бути Контрнаступ
Вони все знають тільки вони ні за що не
відповідають і це неправильно Вони мають
декларуватися і тому після того коли
пані радіна я просто щоб вона дала
відповідь на це питання проголосувала за
декларування офісу президента після
цього їй там хтось подзвонив щось
прийшла якась есемеска І вона сказала що
неможливо встановити результати цього
голосування будемо переголосовувати І
далі вже тільки три сміливих з'явилися
члени комітету і це була панісюмер Я
хочу щоб вона взяла репліку Також я її
згадую спеціально і розказала що
відбулося на цьому комітеті колеги Отже
про що наша поправка 405 вона звучить
так що за неї ну от всі хто не
проголосують я вас запевняю Ми донесемо
позицію до всіх е-е сільрад до всіх
військових Хто це не підтримав Отже
при кінцеві положення встановити що на
період дії воєнного стану введено указом
Президента
виконання функцій держави або місцевого
самоврядування відносяться також радники
помічники президента України давайте
Зеленського підтримаємо друзі Зеленський
декларуються і він робить це для того
щоб Ми повернули декларування Так чого
його радники не декларуються давайте
поможемо пану зеленському і введемо
наступне щоби радники президента
Зеленського задекларувалися також а
також посади які належать до патронатної
служби Та які обіймають їх на
громадських засадах а також радники
помічники офісу президента України
керівника офісу президента
прем'єр-міністра інших членів Кабміну в
тому числі особи посади яких належать до
патронатної служби Та які обіймають їх
на громадських засадах зазначені особи
зобов'язані подати декларацію особи
уповноваженої на виконання функцій це
поправка номер 405 і я переконана що
голосування цієї поправки наближає нашу
країну до ЄС і НАТО і я переконана що
президент Зеленський який хоче відновити
декларування